all right nikki yes mickey where'd you
go where are you from originally um
warminster but i lived just about
everywhere my parents moved around a lot
tell me about your childhood you had mom
and dad
mom and dad
five brothers and a sister
how'd you describe your childhood
complicated
in what ways
outsiders looking in it seemed like the
perfect childhood
what
absolutely not
um
my parents tried hard
i love my parents for trying so hard but
they also
pretended not to know things that they
did know slap a lot of things under the
rug
and this is going to bother a lot of
people in my family and you know what
i don't care
it's about that time
what kind of stuff was going on
i have a twin brother as i said to you
um
me and my twin brother are molested by
well i was molested by two of my
brothers
one to this day still doesn't admit that
even though i went to the school and
told on him
and then my parents moved us out of
state so that they wouldn't take us away
i was six
and then my other brother when they
moved us out of state started molesting
me my twin brother
your parents knew
i don't know how much they knew
but when i was six and went to the
school
they definitely knew
and did absolutely nothing about it
i was six years old and the reason i
went to the school is because he started
touching my little baby sister and she
was only four
this went on for how long
how it was nine
you feel like that changed you
absolutely
how could not
my brother
my poor brother
it's crazy
as much as it hurt me
my brother really really suffered
the one who messaged you
no my twin brother he molested him as
well
i felt more worse for him than i did for
myself
my entire life
that affected him in many many ways
he never said anything to anybody he
finally confronted my mom when we were
about 27.
he said something to my mother about it
but
what did your mom say
nothing as usual
my mother
tried hard to yes
be a good parent
but um
our way of being a good parent was
buying us stuff
i had everything
you know
clothes shoes um
you know
but
i would way
way
would have wanted more affection and
love from my parents i don't ever
remember my father telling me he loved
me
i know he did but he never said it
yeah what was your favorite memory as a
job
going to my grandmother's house
christmas was always so much fun
my growing was great
what kind of kid were you in high school
i quit high school in 10th grade i had
my son at 14 years old
yes
how many kids do you have
six six
five boys and then my daughter she's my
youngest she just had a baby girl
herself
did you raise your kids
um
not all of their lives no
is it because of drugs absolutely yeah
where did the harder drug use start for
you
um
i used drugs when my kids were little um
but the hard drug you started five years
ago
i mean often when my kids were little i
used cocaine and drying beer or whatever
but
heroin started just about five and a
half years ago
fairly recently
and then that turned into
into fentanyl
yes
how long you been
in kensington
just about six years five and a half six
years yeah
yep
tell me about kensington
what's it like living here
crazy
but let me tell you something some of my
closest most dearest friends that i know
i met here in the last five years
people that i consider family
everybody has a different experience
here i'm a very
outspoken person good-hearted i'll do
anything for anybody um
and i always see what others suffer
never never really
it's never about me i always worry about
other people maybe that's my way of
deflecting i'm not sure
it's always about someone else for me
what she's going through or what you
know i mean
i don't know why i've always been like
that
you've been in love before
hey sure i guess
uh married my first husband at 14.
i left him at 19.
second husband at 21 left him at 34 and
since then i've had a couple boyfriends
i don't think i loved any of them to be
quite honest
i have love for them
i don't
i don't love myself right now so i can't
love anyone else
i'm not happy where i'm at yeah this is
not what i want to do
so back to kensington what what do you
do for money here
um lots of things
prostitution being one
that's going to be
a big pill for them to swallow
with a childhood like yours
what do they expect
they expect a whole lot more than that
cause you know
they didn't do nothing wrong i did it
even as a child
in their eyes
content can be fun sometimes
it can be scary sometimes tell me about
the
the best and the worst with kenzie
like i said i met a lot of really good
people out here
just because people do drugs doesn't
make them bad people
ever
doesn't make them bad people what's the
worst thing that's happened to you
i've been raped
more than once
where are you sleeping at
right now i just got my housing oh you
did
yeah good for you thank god
i was on the streets for four and a half
years i was just asleep under that
bridge
is it right that's right that bridge you
just found me at that was my home four
and a half years it's gonna be cold in
the winter
freezing
learn to survive you learn too bad
get on training early in the morning
warm up
turn that back and forth until they
throw you off
because what goes through your mind on
on particularly rough days down here
like what why me what did i do right
where's this so-called people that love
me
you talk to your family still
not really
not for
lack of not trying
they're very selfish and
very self-absorbed
so um i'm good with that
my father just passed away
didn't even attend his funeral
my father decided it was a good idea and
two weeks after my mother passed away to
marry my mom's best friend
two weeks after my mother passed away he
married my mother's best friend you
still talk to your kids
absolutely
absolutely
what emotions do you go through living
down here
oh god so many
lately
i've been really depressed and
lots of emotions have been going on
if i had enough guts i probably would
have jumped in front of a train by now
but i'm not that much
not that courageous i don't think
are you lonely
everybody down here is
very lonely please
what do you worry about
are you afraid of
dying before i get well well enough to
spend more time with my kids
being addicted to fentanyl do you think
there's a good chance you won't
break break away from that
honestly
probably not
you probably won't right
the odds are against you absolutely
and this is a disease and and so they
say
i just think i'm an act but whatever i
like drugs too much
um you like to you like the drugs
yeah they're not feeling
i feel nothing i think about nothing
yeah i'm surprised you went as far as
you as long in
life as you did without
going to the
harder
drugs like fentanyl heroin
going through what you went through
i tried hard for other people once i
didn't really have my kids in my life it
didn't matter much more
like they weren't there they weren't
living with me my daughter moved out and
son moved out and
it was me
i didn't care anymore
has your life changed since since you've
been on this
this path for the last five six years
oh god so many things have changed
i don't know
my health is not good
um
only positive thing right now is getting
my housing that's about the only potent
positive thing in my life right now yeah
that stability is good to have yes it is
it's good to be able to go home at night
even though i don't a lot i'm being
honest i mean i but i can and i do when
i want to you know
it's nice to have some place to be safe
absolutely and warm absolutely
something to eat i'm starving now
actually i get some knee when i leave
you sometimes do you sometimes feel like
life is unfair
every day
what was your favorite memory in your
life
my children are my favorite memories
i love my kids
i hope they know that
always
they get frustrated with me i notice
that just go to rehab like it's so easy
not that easy
but what do you what do you think people
that don't do drugs don't understand
about drug addiction
how hard it
um just to glue a rehab just because
that sickness is
horrible horrible horrible have you
gotten clean before
lifestyle have you gotten clean no no
i've been getting home for five straight
years i've never went to a detox and i
have you indeed
have you od'd
one time thank god
one time long when i first started
getting out
yeah i know
i like to get high but i don't want to
die so i don't try to do
more than i should if that makes sense
but i've uh
been closed
two days ago actually i was like whoa i
told my friend i was like you might want
to get that narg it might need it
it was pretty uh intense that high
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
absolutely
yep and what was the biggest factor in
making you that way
not having my kids around
if your mother that's tough absolutely
are there some up sides to this
lifestyle
there's some benefits to it
[Laughter]
no
i don't see any benefits getting on you
don't have rent to pay yeah
you know what and you know what you're
absolutely right i don't pay my bills
because
the
the one thing you have to be to get with
pathways is you have to be a drug addict
who wants to get clean you don't have to
get clean but you won't have to want to
who's not going to admit to that you
know eventually i want to get clean so
pathways to housing they're awesome
people
definitely are
group seven is the awesomeness
good people there
tell me about doing sex work in
kensington
when i um
honestly i used to boost and um
one of uh
my friends was like you can make way
more money you know
doing dates that's what they call it
doing dates
whatever
having sex for money whatever
um there is no benefits to it
um
it's degrading
um
[Music]
you don't need any nice guys that's all
[ __ ]
none of them are nice they just want one
thing from you and that's it
um
it's degrading very much so
is dangerous must be
absolutely
my friend was just
found in tioga park caught up and
put into trash bags
so yeah
very dangerous they said that she was
tortured
for quite some time before they finally
killed her
very scary
i've been thrown out of a car
yeah
moving to about 45 miles an hour right
here on the eye boom
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
no not use drugs
that's for sure
but it definitely doesn't use the pain
is that why what you're doing
absolutely yeah i don't want to think
i don't want to
remember any of it
i get unless i feel do you hold anger
against your family or your parents
absolutely what happened yeah absolutely
absolutely
it's got to be hard
nicki what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
i think it's hard no matter what you do
because this is not the answer for
anyone
i wouldn't recommend it
all right nikki thank you so much for
sharing your story absolutely wish you
the best of luck thank you happy you got
housing
thank you
you